my name is Nazir Afzal I was the chief
Crown prosecutor in northwest of England
my sister-in-law's nephew hazrat umar
was stabbed to death in birmingham the
best way to deal with grief is to take
some action these are my ideas firstly
police officer numbers have been
devastated twenty-one thousand fewer it
means our neighbourhoods are not being
policed in the same way it means that
police officers aren't being trusted
with information and intelligence it
means that when we tell young people who
run and hide there's nowhere to run and
hide and there's nobody to tell when
they need help and support secondly the
austerity is meant that youth services
children's services or manner of
services for young people are no longer
there the grassroots organizations that
have taken its place don't have the
funding they operate on a shoestring the
young people no longer have the safe
spaces where they can seek help where
they can seek a support where they can
be mentored that means that they're put
at risk they go to places like alleyways
like parks where they were even more at
risk thirdly education research tells us
you can identify the propensity to
violence of a child from the age of four
or five so why are we not teaching them
the consequences of crime now from a
police officer or from a victim and then
it's social media which leads to
isolation why are we not teaching them
social skills so they can deal with
conflict so they can walk away rather
than fight and die when fu hazard Umar
was a teen with tremendous potential
Evan to live for and nothing to die for
I don't want any other family to have to
go through what my families had to go
through I want people to listen I want
people to act I want people to be safe